welcome to this video playing semoran
from Spain many spanish players really I
came let's let's go for the feed or do
something else okay looking for his book
how to beat 1d6 how to be 26 and 20
moves okay he found it and it recommends
93 okay let's see okay we transpose to
the novel three door okay they are
working one that's the main line I try
to play em play traditionally with b6
and so on and they also play a four a
five year hmm b 6 35 I believe oh it's
not doing that okay so i might as well
and try to get get be five in here it
should be seven and b5 to come okay it's
probably going for this regrouping 92mm
and I should cover you five I am ok ok
yeah I want the bishop 108 so that after
night at five I can play g6 easily very
interesting
hmm interesting way to play this see
form hmm see able to play I he might be
able to play see hive at the right
moment yeah interesting question should
i take or should I keep the position
closed I'm not ideally placed for a
closed center but he's also not flexed
well for that really I could play c5
d505 completely completely closing it
down than g6 Bishop g7 that's probably
not the best way to play how objectively
speaking okay I need to need to get get
going he might play a 5 himself so I I
just shut this down yeah I know why
that's not great but i think i'm
reasonably well placed here on the
kingside interesting this I didn't
expect quick edge form I can even play
h5m yeah why not
okay i can try 94 bishop air to age 60
try to exchange the bishop key everyone
is a very strange rules ah this this was
the idea hmm bishop seven maybe after f3
i can take on edge for Queen 228 may be
interesting if I take take i also have
nite nite f8 h7 ok it's just just
dropping back here ok the night needs to
go there anyway i think this this looks
ok for me but ok ok at the time ah the
time not not quite sure where i spent
all the time as usual but ok at least
the position is is fine night h7 i can
take on h4 even so he drops it back
okay I've gotten rid of my my bad bishop
maybe I can prepare a five okay i have i
have two nights we can get a second
night there should i should i play that
though can also exchange the last bishop
in this position check this this looks
strange thus king g 5 0 FF five looks
looks even better we're coming to f7 and
then a form if possible okay I better do
this now now I even have f3 ever like
time or i guess i should i should take
here first and and open up open up the
position okay g6 and h7 can give one
chick
hmm that's a bit a bit awkward maybe
like this
and yeah Queen g6 sir Queen g6 looks
looks like a problem a stupid very
stupid this was certainly just good for
me and this is of course not good aah
chak and I takes it with a check so just
just very bad play ok let's resign this
black resigns yeah this was this was a
bit of a shame as he basically outplayed
himself him here black should just win
of course if how should I win therefore
is right I just need to be precise in
this in this person in this position
here King age 8 this winning yeah this
covers covers thinks reliably and look
GA drew g7 ask I'm just having a having
a deadly attack here is absolutely
nothing white can do against this the
bishop is actually very silly piece in
this position I played the only
composable continuation to make it
active again I mean this is this also
winning Queen f six wins and then queen
age six but after this it's not clear
absolutely not the compounds to play
Luke g8 which is least a draw Luke g8 us
however move you don't really like to
play yeah very stupid way to lose this
Queen d7 is still ok for black and yeah
oh I just play 93 and he resigns Chan
what did what what game is this I can
just take away all his pieces huh
ah just this and and and over I mean
this is just just just some sexy oh yeah
mmm great game I played here and shaft
was changing oh man okay yeah this was
was quite interesting strategically here
whitis is just just better but he is
playing a very weird moves to be honest
cooking everyone is just just weird yes
sir yeah maybe he really prepared
prepared this idea night h2 is jacked
and interesting try to just get the bond
it's not easy for him to cover this okay
and I just played the the normal stuff
trying to exchange my bed pieces for his
good pieces and step out step white cops
got pushed back fy4 saucer I just wanted
to have a central position yeah queen d
7 is also strong yeah maybe this is even
stronger threatening this and after this
move f5 is this winning as well yeah I
said this was just terribly played by
black by me I should never ever survive
this okay wow thanks for watching